Brad and Angelina are reportedly set to
sell off every one of their
multimillion-dollar properties that they
owned together and the first on the
market could be the crown jewel of their
worldwide real-estate Empire Brad Pitt
and Angelina Jolie are reportedly ready
to sell their estate in the South of
France Chateau Miraval the twelve
hundred acre property includes a moat
olive grove 35 rooms and a successful
vineyard you got to get out of this
property you don't want to be in
business obviously with your ex so there
are a few different ways you could
approach it you can sell it outright and
you both take your share and you're done
with it or you buy the other out in fact
that's exactly what brad pitt did with
Jennifer Aniston he bought her half of
the production company that they had
together so quite possibly he could do
the same thing here the estate dates
back to the 17th century the jolie-pitt
Miraval timeline however picks up in
2008 that's when the couple first
started leasing the property they bought
it in 2012 for an estimated 60 million
dollars and the following year 2013 they
launched Mirabal wines it's exciting to
see how many countries of distributing
this wine in 2014 Brad and Angie tied
the knot on the property their marriage
may not have worked out but their wine
well it's practically a phenomenon the
first six thousand bottles of the rose'
reportedly sold out within five hours of
going online first of all celebrity
factor alone helps any winery and so
what they did was they brought in a
wonderful wine maker who was really able
to help them do the most with the land
and they want a lot of awards next the
brad pitt investigation ET has learned
that the results of the Department of
Children and Family Services
investigation into pit is imminent that
of course focused on allegations
surrounding an incident between Brad and
his son maddox on a private jet in
September
you